[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du sky échos je vous souhaite une
excellente année 2021 l'année de tous
les défis économiques et un défi à
d'ores et déjà commencé dès le 1er
janvier avec la sortie du royaume uni de
l'union européenne
le bric site et ses conséquences c'est
la thématique de cette émission
dans ce magazine patricia gaudin chef du
pôle action économique à la direction
régionale des douanes de paris-ouest
nous expliquera l'impact sur les
échanges avec les britanniques dans les
yvelines
les nouvelles démarches à engager pour
les entreprises et pour illustrer tout
cela nous aurons l'exemple de la société
axon l'implanter à trappes qui importe
et exporte vers le royaume uni
c'était le 24 décembre dernier la fin du
suspense autour du bric sites européens
et britanniques se sont mis d'accord sur
les conditions de commerce et de
coopération après la sortie de l'union
européenne l'accord a été signé le 30
décembre par le premier ministre
britannique
boris johnson et la président de la
commission européenne ursula von der
leyen
et cela après des mois de négociations
diriger du côté européen par le français
michel barnier on écoute justement
ursula von der leyen et michel barnier
lors d'une conférence de presse le 24
décembre dernier
les négociations ont été très difficiles
avec de tels enjeux pour tant de monde
c'était un accord pour lequel il fallait
se battre
il permettra d'éviter des perturbations
majeures pour les travailleurs les
entreprises et les voyageurs
après le 1er janvier il protègera les
intérêts européens
il y aura donc malgré cet accord de
vrais changements dans quelques jours le
1er janvier
pour beaucoup de citoyens et pour
beaucoup d'entreprises c'est la
conséquence du break site
c'est la conséquence du président nous
avons aussi construit un nouveau
partenariat pour l'avenir autour de
quatre piliers d'abord un accord de
libre-échange ambitieux équitable
free and fair trade fair une frite rides
sans tarif ni quota est au coeur de cet
accord il y à de nouvelles règles du jeu
économique
alors les trois autres piliers sont des
politiques transversales à la fois le
social le transport l'environnement la
recherche mais aussi la sécurité mais
nous allons nous intéresser aux
questions économiques avec notre invité
patriciens gaudin bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes là chef du pôle action
économique aux douanes régionales de
paris ouest
c'est à saint germain en laye alors on
vient d'entendre michel barnier dit que
c'est un accord de libre échange
et pourtant ce sera différent pourquoi
alors l'accord de libre-échange vient
réguler les échanges mais il faut pas
oublier que le président a eu lieu dont
kylie a désormais des formalités
douanières lors de toute importation ou
exportation avec le royaume uni
c'est à dire que depuis 93 1993 nous
étions dans un régime de libre
circulation ou les marchandises de
circuler librement sans formalité
puisqu'il y avait uniquement une
déclaration à faire de façon mensuelle
et récapitulative là les choses sont
totalement différente puisqu'il y a
désormais comme pour des exportations
vers la suisse ou vers les etats unis
une déclaration en douane à établir lors
de chaque mouvement de marchandises
alors il a dit déclaration aux douanes
ne dit pas systématiquement des droits
de douane à payer tout à fait donc
justement l'accord de libre échange est
venu institué une suppression des droits
de douanes entre le royaume uni et
l'union européenne mais avec une raison
c'est à dire que cela s'applique aux
marchandises qui sont originaires du
royaume uni ou de l'union européenne et
la suisse vient de chine qui le qu'il
est à portée sur le territoire
britannique et qui ensuite doit aller
sur le territoire européen
il sera taxé exactement il sera taxé au
tarif extérieur commun de l'union
européenne c'est à dire que par exemple
si vous commandez à une société
britannique des t-shirts qui ont été
fabriqués au bangladesh ou en chine et
qui ont été simplement je dirais floqué
au grande bretagne vous paierez des
droits de douane de l'ordre de 11 ce
tous pour cent quelles démarches elles
doivent engager aujourd'hui les
entreprises et notamment celles dont
vous intéresser les entreprises
yvelinoise alors les entreprises doivent
engager des formalités surtout si elles
n'ont jamais été amené à faire de
l'import ou de l'export puisque celles
qui sont vraiment primo-exportateurs il
faut déjà prend premier lieu qu'elle
s'enregistrent en tant que exportateurs
ou importateurs dans une base
communautaire donc c'est une démarche à
faire auprès de nos services qui est
très simple mais il rien d'automatique
il faut faire la démarche
ensuite ceux notamment qui exportent des
produits fabriqués dans l'union
européenne
ils ont également une démarche à faire
c'est se faire enregistrer comme
exportateurs agréés pour pouvoir
certifier l'origine préférentielle de
leurs produits au gym préférentiels en
gros le produit et réalisé dans l'union
européenne
alors il ya des conditions il ya des
règles qui sont définis en fonction de
la nature des produits donc cet accord
comporte toute une partie qui va
indiquer justement par type de produits
quels sont les règles applicables
donc très souvent par exemple dans le
domaine de l'industrie ce sera soit un
changement de nomenclature douanière à
l'occasion de la transformation qui a
été effectuée soit un maximum de valeur
de produits autres que européen et
justement patricia bonner je vous
propose de découvrir une entreprise
située à trappes à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'entreprise
ac sol elle est spécialisée dans les
produits destinés aux personnes en
situation de handicap elle importe et
exporte ce type de produit depuis le
royaume-uni regarder les détails dans ce
reportage
c'est tout nouveau pour nous mettre
désormais ces produits sont fabriqués en
france
à trappes il ya encore six mois nous les
importerons de grande bretagne
désormais nous nous préparons les
réexporter sur le marché britannique
c'est l'une des activités de cette
entreprise impactés par le break site la
fabrication de ces rampes d'accès pour
les personnes à mobilité réduite
implantée à trappes axle a conçu cet
atelier de production en juillet 2020
après le rachat d'une société
britannique
l'atelier était en angleterre étaient
près de manchester effectivement une
société qui existait depuis 35 ans et
donc été amenée malheureusement a déposé
le bilan sain mars fin mars 2002 or et
nous étions leurs plus gros clients
or hors uk le dirigeant d'axle a préféré
internaliser cette production pour avoir
le contrôle
avec ensuite la volonté d'exporter au
royaume uni la difficulté pour lui en
janvier 2021 à quel prix peut-il vendre
ses produits
aujourd'hui vendre un particulier en
grande-bretagne pour moins de 135 livres
sterling c'est le particulier qui va
payer la tva plus de 135 livres sterling
celle l'exportateur qui payent la tva
plus les frais de transport qui vont
légèrement augmenter
autre impact pour cette entreprise sur
cette chaise d'évacuation pour personnes
en situation de handicap
axsun importe plusieurs de ses produits
auprès d'un fournisseur britannique des
biens à distribuer ensuite en france la
sortie du royaume uni de l'union
européenne va avoir quelques
conséquences
de l'incertitude grandissante du brésil
début décembre nous avions décidé
d'apporter 3 mois de stocks
malheureusement en angleterre à la mi
décembre tous les transports ont été
stoppées maintenant tout est organisé au
niveau des transporteurs en tout cas en
ce qui me concerne leurs systèmes ont
été modifiés
donc les procédures de déclaration de
marchandises vont être faites comme on
fait déjà pour la suisse où les autres
pays en réunion donc en fait la belgique
devrait l'impliquer donc plus de papier
plus d'administratif mais également des
délais de livraison plus long cette
société emploie 14 personnes attrapées
réalise 2 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires alors patricia gaudin on
vient le voir à cette entreprise s'est
préparé on va le voir sur ces images un
peu puis le référendum sur le bric site
en 2016 vous avez organisé plusieurs
réunions d'information un destiné aux
entreprises des zips line questions
simples aujourd'hui les entreprises vise
yvelinoise sont elles prêtes
une partie est prête au vu des questions
que nous avons là depuis le début de la
semaine toutes ne sont pas prêtes à
puisqu'on a effectivement des questions
qui coupent que pour un certain nombre
c'est la découverte de la réalité de la
situation
il faut dire à leur décharge qui est
quand même plusieurs reports de date de
la mise en place du plexi tu met
effectivement en dépit des dernières
actions de communication que nous avions
fait sous forme de webinaires au dernier
trimestre 2009 un lieu encore des
sociétés effectivement qui ne sont pas
totalement préparés à la différence de
celles que vous avez pu montrer quelles
sont les principales problématiques
auxquelles font face les entreprises
chinoises face aux briques site très
souvent c'est des questions très très
simple c'est à dire une société qui est
amenée
expédier des produits sains clients au
royaume uni et qui va effectivement de
contacter pour savoir quels documents
elle doit fournir désormais ou alors
elle nous contactent parce que le
transporteur qu'elle a contacté lui a
demandé de se rapprocher de nos services
pour se faire enregistrer sur la
plateforme rex qui concerne justement
l'attestation d'origine préférentiel
règles se permet en fait de faciliter le
passage des biens d'origine européen à
la boyne en fait alors elle rex permet
véritablement de d'attester de l'origine
préférentielle sur des documents
commerciaux sur la facture il ya une
phrase type a mentionné et à partir du
moment où vous êtes exportateurs agréés
avec cet agrément rex vous pouvez le
faire quelle que soit la valeur de
l'envoi mais ça ne suffit pas à côté ça
il ya de toute façon une déclaration en
douane et pour qu'il y ait une fluidité
au niveau du passage au niveau des ports
de calais et dunkerque eux notamment
il faut anticiper c'est à dire qu'il
faut vraiment prévoir qui va réaliser
les formalités de dédouanement et
communiquer tous les éléments
nécessaires pour que ce soit fait avant
que les marchandises n'arrive sur les
ports de calais et dunkerque
c'est ça ce qui permet véritablement
d'utiliser le système informatique qui a
été mis en place par la douane justement
pour avoir le maximum de fluidité compte
tenu du nombre très important de poids
lourds qui passe mais ce système enfin
qu'on appelle une frontière intelligente
ne peut fonctionner que si tous les
opérateurs de la chaîne travail en amont
merci patricia gaudin pour toutes ces
précisions je rappelle que vous êtes là
chef du pôle action économique à la
direction régionale des douanes de paris
ouest est pour et pour tout complété
pour tout complément d'information pour
les entreprises qui ont besoin
d'informations sur le break 6 qui a
d'abord le guide douanier de préparation
aux briques site sur le site internet
des douanes pour les sociétés yvelinoise
de contacts intéressants aux adresses
mail suivante p a retiré paris tire et
west ham
as douanes point finances.gouv.fr ou le
bureau de douane deux trappes joignable
à gestion tirer procédure tirer trappe
@ douanes point finances.gouv.fr et vous
le savez l'année 2020 a été marquée par
la crise économique engendrée par la
crise sanitaire et c'est dans ce
contexte que saint quentin en yvelines a
voté un plan de relance de 2 millions
d'euros en juin
et parmi les dispositifs le pré
initiative sky toujours proposé par
l'agglomération
un fonds d'un million d'euros proposés
donc je le disais par le conseil
d'agglomération cette aide est un prêt
d'honneur attribué aux entreprises de 10
à 50 salariés
avec un montant pouvant aller jusqu'à
100 mille euros sans garantie et à taux
zéro et si vous souhaitez faire la
demande de ce dispositif les
informations au 01 39 30 31 30 51 30 ou
dave échos @ sky point fr et c'est la
fin de cette émission émission à revoir
en replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]